and what we're talking about here is not
genetic manipulation or UV gemach sore
any of these somewhat dubious
enterprises with a clouded history but
using technological prosthesis to extend
them in rich humaneness to enrich
communication and it is believe me the
want of good communication that is the
thing probably if anything undoes us
this will be it that our languages
failed that we miss read each other's
intent that we could not understand each
other so the the project of refining
language is is the same project as the
ending of history I mean history is the
story of languages that failed and when
language grows perfect history will end
and it made language may not look like
it looks today or sound like it sounds
today the realization that's flowered in
the wake of the internet and the rise of
cybernetics is that everything is made
of information information is the
primary data muff being concepts like
time and space and energy are orders of
magnitude removed from the present at
hand when compared with a concept like
information and and as Mark said every
iota every bit of information that
passes through it that we generate that
we transmit changes us so I'm seeing
here almost the Theosophical epiphany of
language trying to bootstrap itself
toward realms of platonic perfection
which as organic beings we experience as
love
love beauty truth these are the vectors
of human becoming they always have been
they always will be and the technologies
that open these paths for it are no more
and no less powerful than the human
beings that wield them
[Music]